good morning everyone mayor Jimenez has
been briefed by emergency managers as
well as by the National Weather Service
this morning he'll have the latest for
you in just a moment as a reminder we'll
be doing English comments first followed
by English questions and then we will
have Spanish comments followed by
Spanish questions that will be followed
by comments by our translator in Haitian
Creole thank you to all our elected
officials who are here today as well as
our department directors and with that
here's miami-dade County Mayor Carlos
Gimenez Thank You Patti and again thank
you to all of our elected officials that
are here joining me at the podium this
morning good morning everybody
you know our prayers go out to our
neighbors in the Bahamas as they
confront hurricane durian for us in
South Florida the message today is
prepare wait and see overnight the
projections for a hurricane Dorian's
path shifted slightly to the north
however it is still expected to be a
powerful hurricane north of us while
this is good news for miami-dade County
it's still way too early
to let our guard down small changes in
the trajectory can have a major impact
for us in terms of how we prepare so we
all need to prepare to wait and to see
just because some parts of miami-dade
are out of the cone does not mean that
we will not have hazardous weather there
is a fifty to seven per 70 percent
chance and probability of tropical storm
force winds along with possible storm
surges so again let's prepare let's wait
and let's see don't take down your
shutters not just yet
last night President Trump called me to
assure us that Miami Dade County can
count on the federal government's help I
want to thank the president for that
very important offer our County also
remains ready to lend our assistance to
others who might need it no matter where
this storm lands yesterday I signed an
emergency declaration for Miami Dade
County this allows us to hire
contractors as needed it also gives me
certain powers such as calling for a
curfew if needed at this point the
declaration remains we must keep our
guards up as we continue to monitor
Hurricane Dorian we have raised concerns
about construction camp cranes in our
county state of Florida and governor Ron
de Santos
hurt us the state of has temporarily
suspended preemption of hurricane
preparation provisions for tower cranes
and hoisting equipment a a problem
really pretty unique to miami-dade
County because of all the high-rise
cranes that we have here
I thank governor Ron de santis and
Florida Division of Emergency Management
Director Jaret Moskowitz the new crane
rules will help ensure the safety of our
residents this action means that
provisions of miami-dade County code 80
- 80 - 11 hurricane preparedness are
applicable and can be enforced
countywide until September 10th 2019
unless otherwise directed by the state
as crane operators secure their
equipment in the county we closely
monitor Dorian's path at this time all
miami-dade county services are
continuing their normal operations most
recent models show potential divergence
and Dorian's path starting on Sunday so
for today we have postponed the movement
of all our special needs in vacuous we
will make a decision tonight by 7:00
o'clock as to whether we will need to
move our special needs residents
starting tomorrow morning we of course
are keeping all of those people informed
all residents need to be aware that we
have king tides as holiday weekend these
tides will continue through Tuesday they
occur from approximately 10:00 a.m. to
12:00 noon and then again from 10:00
p.m. to midnight the king tide brings in
additional foot or more of water with
the ground already saturated from this
week's rain the king tides can lead to
flooding in areas where there is already
standing water so we advise everyone to
be cautious especially from 10 o'clock
to noon and from 10 o'clock at night to
midnight from today through Tuesday by
now everyone should be completing all
hurricane preparations as I've stated
before residents should make sure that
emergency equipment such as battery
powered radios are in good working order
finished putting up the shutters test
your generators get fuel for them also
top off your tanks for your cars if
you're on medications make sure you have
a full supply or get refills immediately
ensure that sufficient emergencies of
such as non-perishable goods and food
and water are on hand for each person in
the home to last for three days you
don't need to go out and buy water Miami
Dade's tap water is just fine just open
the tap you can drink all you want
finished moving lawn furniture inside
secure all yard and construction debris
so they do not pose a hazard during a
storm
the county solid waste department is
working diligently on extended hours to
pick up all bulky trash requests and
they will continue to do so until winds
get too strong so even even if we are
now under less of a threat things can
change quickly take those tree trimmings
to a local trash and recycling center
which are extended hours from 7 o'clock
in the morning to 7 o'clock at night we
have 13 locations that you can find out
where they are by calling three one one
or going online to miami-dade gov
backslash solid waste find out if you
live in an evacuation zone that
information is available on miami-dade
gov if you live in a surgeon sewn you
must have an evacuation plan plan the
leave with ample time to get to a safe
area zone maps are available on the
website miami-dade dot-gov backslash om
while we have not issued an evacuation
order we do we do want everyone to know
if they live NH in evacuation area so
that they can get out early on Thursday
state attorney general Katherine
Fernandez Rundle activated the number to
call to ensure that there is no price
gouging aid in advance of the storm the
number for that hotline is 305 five four
seven three three zero zero that's three
oh five five four seven three three zero
zero if you haven't already download our
hurricane readiness guide at miami-dade
gov it has information in English in
Spanish and Haitian Creole you can also
download a free app called ready
miami-dade finally placed please take
the time to sign up for miami-dade
alerts and for now we again we will
prepare we will wait and we
we'll see and now I'll answer any
questions in English yeah we had we had
anticipated that we would be picking up
our special needs residents and taking
them to shelter today but in light of
what's happened with this new tract or
the way that the storm is going or piers
to be going we're gonna be postponing
that we have sufficient time if the
storm takes a turn towards us we have
sufficient time to pick them up and take
them to the shelter so again let's let's
prepare let's wait this let's see and so
for us it didn't make any sense to pick
them up and and put them in a shelter I
think a lot of them would have probably
said no we really don't want to be
picked up right now and so it's much
better just to leave them where they are
and we'll pick them up if if the time
comes if need be right now it doesn't
appear that we're gonna have to do that
but if we we have to do that we have
plenty of time to do it
well the president pledged his full
support of the federal government to the
state of Florida and to miami-dade
County if if need be he was very
gracious I know the president also you
know personally so we had we had some
you know conversations about you know
that between us but the the official
part was his willingness to help the
state of Florida and in miami-dade
County and that he was watching out for
what was what was happening and I
believe he was in Camp David so that's
where he's gonna be watching what's
happening here in the state and and he's
promised all the federal help so I you
know I thanked him for that and and he
was very gracious in that
well if it continues on its on its track
its projected track you know we'll be
out of the tropical storm-force window
so right now there's still a probability
of 50 to 60% that will have tropical
storm-force winds here in miami-dade
County again we need to wait and see you
exactly where the storm goes we make
these calls based on how much time we
have so we have time they also expect
the storm to slow down a little bit and
so all these calls are made in
conjunction with the National Hurricane
Center and our in our weather office
here in in miami-dade and so we had
briefings this morning from personnel
from the National Weather Service and
and so we're pretty confident and we're
very confident in the steps that we're
taking right now we want to make sure
that everybody continues with their
preparations because if this storm turns
quickly towards us then we need to need
to move but at this point again we just
need to see what the storm is doing as
long as it continues on its project on a
projected path this course of action is
fine
we got people here we're constantly
watching monitoring the storm if somehow
projections changed then our actions
will change but that's all it's all
contingent upon upon what the storm does
no they the cranes uh it's a lot of
these cranes that take some you know
some days for them to come down so
they're there's certain things that they
have to do to secure them we had put
that in the in a miami-dade county code
that had be preempted by the state the
governor yesterday has waived those
provisions that preemption from the from
the of the state and then allowed our
local building officials and miami-dade
County - now enforce those provisions so
that there are certain provisions things
that they have to do they're not going
to have to do it there's a long list of
them a lot of very technical grandma I
was not gonna it's not gonna do them
okay so she may be worried about it but
you know it's okay you know you know the
like the tower crane turntable has to be
lubricated I don't think she's gonna be
doing that but but but yeah these are
things that we want to make sure that
the cranes turn you know into the wind
and that we don't have an issue we
actually had an issue was some with with
a last hurricane we had where it wasn't
secured in that fashion and the the
counterweight fell and fortunately
didn't hit metro or Metro mover but it
fell right between the two paths of
Metro movers so those are those are some
of things there's a whole list of things
they have to do just to make sure that
they're secure they didn't have to do
that because we were preempted by the
state the state now allows us to to
apply those laws during this time and I
want to thank the governor for doing
that any other questions okay